she'll you mentioned in a prior
interview about the late Tim
Hetherington of Restrepo and other
journalists who have lost their lives on
assignment how many times a day a week
did it cross your mind that the same
thing could happen to you
you know you tryna I've been a
photojournalist for a very long time and
you kind of try not to think about it
while you're always thinking how to stay
safe
um this film was definitely taking a
risk you know the decision going down
there is that we're gonna make a drug
war film that's not gonna be experts
it's not gonna be talking heads that's
gonna put you in the front row and
really make you feel not learn but
really feel what it feels like to be in
horrors to be in this reality to be in
the midst of it so sure we had a couple
of bad runs and I've had colleagues
including Tim Heatherton that have died
but I think you kind of you know you
really concentrate on on being careful
and I'm pushing and doing what you want
and you kind of block out at the same
time this wow this could be over like
that and that was that was kind of the
balance that we struck we ended up going
to horrors more than 20 times we always
stayed for a very short time we had our
little systems in place it was a very
small two-man crew we tried to not be
visible we try to not step on any wrong
toes not open stuff we shouldn't does
the question cross your mind why make a
film if it may be my last time no
because and I think that that was
actually Tim's having ten messages
you never know when it's gonna happen if
it does and if you always think that way
then us photojournalist filmmakers I
really go to the front lines we'll never
do any of it because if you live in fear
then it's possible anywhere I could step
outside and something would happen so
you gotta you gotta push everybody has
their own destiny
and for you Edgar with the narcocorrido
movement is it more about respect
than just sort of guns and drugs and you
know the money and women is it more
about rising up and people gaining of
affluence through this whole yeah I
think it's it's about respect
everywhere you go not only in that I
think you respect the next man he'll
respect you back and and sometimes
people I guess I want to feel good by
listening to this type of music or any
type of music anything that makes you
feel good you want to listen to it right
and and in my type of business you can
actually call me up and if you want you
know I write a song about you and and
and and I and I go back on that if
there's a certain line that you got a
you know put yourself it just don't
cross that and don't disrespect anybody
and you'll be good one of the comments
on YouTube and it was in Spanish and I
put it in Google Translate and it said
there are countless ways to change the
world but the way these individuals
behave it's like a volcano about to
erupt what are your thoughts um what
what individual this the whole narco
that there are ways to change and to
rise up but is this the right way to do
it it's been erupting since 1910 because
that's like the farthest go deal that I
know so I guess it's it's a non antipope
cable no it's uh I don't um how can I
say this is it's just a it's just what's
in it's it's it's something popular I
guess it is if if it's a volcano today
tomorrow's gonna be an avalanche but
this is matter something's always gonna
happen well there's a great scene in the
film where you're on a farm I think you
commented how peaceful and calm it was
do you ever longed for that life yeah
that's why I say sometimes I would love
to go and live in Mexico I would love to
go and I
I don't know this has been playing at
times when I die tell me so maybe in
another life you were out in and in some
and some ranch with cows and because
sometimes I feel like even though I'm
born and raised in Los Angeles
California I feel like I'm I can I can
relate more to people from the ranch
then people from the city and I guess it
yeah it just it does make you it makes
me feel a little more peaceful without
out in Mexico does did I hear you say
that you feel that the war on drugs is
essentially hopeless um you know I don't
know if it's hopeless but it's not
looking good and it's this thing that we
love talking away in the u.s. it's it's
Mexico's drug war that sounds really far
although 50 40 to 50 billion dollars
here come from here
guns come from here the demand comes
from here so it's helpless if we don't
change it it's in our hands we have to
at least make a real attempt and you
know and part of the reason to making
this movie is because people always said
oh it's just gangsters killing gangsters
no it affects everybody
Edgard songs don't reach only gangsters
actually the majority of them are create
American Latino kids who go to a party
Cena and to connect to something that
they hear about but if we let the bad
guys win if impunity is so vast then it
is hopeless because what one thing is
that's not going to stop and we got to
be real as a demand and the price and
the huge business here hasn't stopped
for many many years so right now if you
live through it like I did
it feels hopeless in Ritchie's world in
in horrors yes it feels very hopeless
it's so sad you can't this irony that we
saw again and again sure broke my heart
it felt like nobody's paying attention
and everything's obvious I think you
quoted mexico's president we're living
next to the biggest drug addict in the
world which is the US
I am me and many other journalists
quoted him saying I don't remember the
exact quote of how it's hard to be the
neighbor of the biggest drug addict in
the world and it's true I totally
understand that um you know if the US
wasn't there then with its demand then
none of this would have happened
including Edgar's careers and song
wouldn't be there thank you thank you